[Musica]
all
saltato
bentrovati parlare di cultura di futuro
della cultura parlare di luoghi della
cultura oggi vuol dire sicuramente
parlare anche della rete la cultura è
anche comunicazione è un aspetto
fondamentale è quello della
comunicazione per la cultura e
l'ambiente comunicativo l'ecosistema
della comunicazione di oggi soprattutto
per le giovani generazioni è
indubbiamente la rete dobbiamo allora
anche domandarci come si muove come si è
sviluppata dove sta andando la rete se
ci vogliamo chiedere come si sta
sviluppando dove sta andando la cultura
io vi per proporre di cominciare questo
nostro viaggio con una ventina di
secondi di un film famoso un film ormai
di parecchia mi fa più per staff via
brighenti times desco
[Musica]
magari qualcuno di voi avrà riconosciuto
ai war games un film del 1983 sono
passati 36 anni e war games è un film è
importante perché il primo film di
cassetta di grande successo in cui
compare la figura del merda del
ragazzino che usa i suoi computer i need
a casa e sono ancora degli home computer
assolutamente primitivi per comunicare
con altri computer in questo caso prima
con il computer della scuola dove cerca
di cambiare i suoi voti e quelli della
sua amichetta e poi con il computer del
pentagono rischiando di far scoppiare
una guerra termonucleare in war games
per la prima volta il computer viene
presentato non solo come uno strumento
per macinare numeri per fare calcoli o
per giocare ma come anche uno strumento
di comunicazione uno strumento per
collegare tra di loro risorse di tipo
diverso per interagire con risorse
informative war games dicevamo del 1983
e segna forse l'inizio di quella che
potremmo chiamare la prima epoca della
rete un'epoca in cui ci si collegava
internet per poco tempo i ragazzini war
games usava un accoppiatore acustico
l'antenato dei modem ci si collegava per
20 minuti per mezz'ora e si cercava di
catturare un po quello che si trovava ai
territori della rete erano ancora
territori largamente inesplorati
cominciavano a costituirsi e si
portavano le prede informative catturate
nella grotta nel proprio computer e poi
si consumava questo pasto informativa
male vedere cosa si era riusciti a
catturare era un po un'epoca di
cacciatori raccoglitori delle tribù di
pionieri ancora relativamente piccole
che cominciavano esplorare questi
territori
la situazione cambia quando cambia
sostanzialmente intorno all'inizio degli
anni 90 quando si comincia a diffondere
il web
non bisogna mai confondere internet con
il web internet esisteva già prima il
web nasce all'inizio degli anni 90 e
porta a tutto un altro tipo di metafore
si parla di siti web sostanzialmente
questi territori cominciano essere
urbanizzati si comincia a coltivare
informazione in maniera organizzata
quella pagina che vedete è la pagina
oggi sembrerebbe bruttissimo webmaster
di oggi guarderebbe con orrore e quella
pagina web era la pagina di geositi sono
dei primi strumenti che permetteva di
creare siti web siamo alla metà degli
anni 90 e gestiti se era tutto
organizzato intorno alla metafora dei
centri urbani atene erano le pagine
dedicate alla letteratura alla filosofia
parigi quelle dedicate all'arte alla
musica
l'area 51 quella dedicata alla
fantascienza al fantasy proprio
l'urbanizzazione l'idea
dell'urbanizzazione di questi territori
di rete e proprio come le prime città
i primi siti web erano fatti di edifici
informativi di scarsa complessità bassi
collegati tra di loro e un'infinità di
stradine di scalette la rete all'inizio
questi primi centri urbani di rete erano
centri ancora complessità molto bassa in
cui l'informazione veniva coltivata per
così dire in maniera stanziale
all'interno del sito
un passaggio successivo è quello a
quello che viene spesso chiamato web 2.0
io ho messo alla data del 2011 come data
di cambiamento se ne potrebbero anche
scegliere altri molti indicano una
famosa conferenza del settembre del 2000
ma cosa succede io ho messo la data del
2011 pensando all 11 settembre del 2011
sapete
2011 si le torri gemelle del 2001
scusate le torri gemelle e cosa succede
che l'undici settembre i siti
informativi tradizionali il sito della
cnn
vanno in crash sono troppo sovraccarichi
di richieste non riescono più a
rispondere alle richieste degli utenti
cominciano a duplicare
quell'informazione su altri siti ci si
accorge che l'informazione può essere
duplicata condivisa può viaggiare da un
sito all'altro e si afferma
progressivamente un nuovo paradigma che
quello dei social network dello user
generated content del contenuto generato
dagli utenti
siamo passati dall età dei primi centri
urbani o dell'agricoltura informativa
all'età dell'artigianato e del commercio
che largamente l'età in cui ci troviamo
noi oggi un'epoca in cui costruiamo
artigianalmente informazione ciascuno di
noi oggi soprattutto con gli smartphone
costruisce informazione granulare a
bassa complessità artigianalmente
anche se gli strumenti sono
sofisticatissimi la condivide la fa
viaggiare dietro il web 2.0 ci sono
questi convogli di informazione
granulare un po delle specie di carovane
di informazione granulare che fanno
circolare informazione e se ci fermiamo
un momento a riflettere su quelle che
sono le caratteristiche di questo eco
sistema informativo anche dal punto di
vista della cultura
ci rendiamo conto che questa
informazione che circola oggi in rete e
per l'appunto prevalentemente granulare
pensate alle mail pensate ai messaggi
whatsapp pensate al post di un blog
pensato ai messaggi di status un social
network alle storie su instagram sono
prevalentemente contenuti brevi
frammentati granulari la tradizione
della cultura più complessa più
sofisticata quella della cultura del
libro in cui noi in fondo abbiamo
imparato a dar forma
complessità è rimasta un po ai margini
di questo sviluppo della rete
ora ci possiamo domandare come mai
l'informazione che circola oggi in là in
rete prevalentemente granulare è una
caratteristica essenziale del digitale è
quello di privilegiare informazione
granulare di per sé il digitale solo un
meccanismo di codifica dell'informazione
io posso codificare in digitale un tweet
di 140 caratteri
oppure guerre pace cambia niente dal
punto di vista della codifica perché
allora preferiamo questi contenuti brevi
granulari io credo che una parte della
risposta sia proprio legata
all'evoluzione della rete è proprio
legata al tipo di strumenti che usiamo
oggi cioè la granularità non è una
caratteristica essenziale della rete è
una caratteristica della rete come la
conosciamo oggi al suo stadio di
sviluppo attuale noi abbiamo senso
sempre un po la tendenza a immaginarci
alla fine della storia
ma siamo dentro la storia e in questo
caso siamo dentro una storia che ancora
molto giovane
cominciamo già a renderci conto che
anche in rete da questa organizzazione
prevalentemente frammentata e granulare
dell'informazione si comincia a passare
in alcuni casi wiki pd è forse l'esempio
più chiaro a delle forme di
organizzazione più sofisticata più
complessa
forse ci avviamo verso un'età di
cattedrali digitali o metà delle
cattedrali in cui contenuti digitali
potranno essere anche più complessi
anche perché costruiti in maniera sempre
più spesso collaborativa e recuperare
questa complessità vuol dire anche
recuperare una parte importante della
nostra tradizione culturale le giovani
generazioni oggi le generazioni dell'età
dell'artigianato e del commercio hanno
un'enorme capacità di movimento
orizzontale
male da un'informazione all'altra hanno
in genere una minore capacità di
comprensione produzione di contenuti
verticalmente complessi ora intendiamoci
questa capacità di movimento orizzontale
che si è sviluppata di collegamento
veloce tra informazioni è una capacità
importante positiva sono molto più bravi
i giovani di oggi di quanto non era la
mia generazione per esempio a muoversi e
collegare rapidamente le cose però è
importante anche recuperare questa
capacità legate all'organizzazione
verticale complessa dell'informazione
non solo perché l'informazione complessa
strutturata costruita e un modo solido
per fare cultura ma anche perché il
futuro glielo chiederà
i ragazzi di oggi in futuro dovranno
lavorare sempre più spesso anche con
informazione complessa e strutturata e
quindi questo di recuperare le
competenze per lavorare anche in
digitale oggi soprattutto in digitale su
informazione strutturata e complessa beh
questo è un bisogno formativo importante
essenziale a cui le istituzioni
formative la scuola l'università
dovrebbero cercare sempre più di
rispondere una risposta che è importante
anche da un altro punto di vista perché
dopo l'età delle cattedrali già comincia
ad affacciarsi qualcosa cominciamo a
vedere un'età di rivoluzione industriale
potremmo dire che questo paragone un po
azzardato ma spero di una qualche
utilità tra l'evoluzione della società
umana e l'evoluzione della rete un'età
di rivoluzione industriale in cui si
produce informazione attraverso
informazione in cui agenti software
producono contenuti anche al posto delle
persone possiamo forse far partire un
filmato più che altro una suggestione su
cui vorrei poi salutarvi e un
firmato che è stato realizzato da un
video artista turco refik a nadal che ha
lavorato con google a cercare di dar
forma all'immagine del futuro degli
archivi gli archivi sono una delle
istituzioni tradizionali di memoria di
conservazione e anche di cultura perché
memoria e contatto con il passato sono
bassi per il lavoro culturale
oggi questi archivi sognati
in questo video sono sempre più archivi
digitali archivi legati a una
informazione su cui si lavora attraverso
agenti software indipendenti questo
futuro in cui l'informazione produce
altra informazione in maniera in parte
indipendente il futuro dell'intelligenza
artificiale e un futuro che ha aspetti
affascinanti ma anche aspetti
preoccupanti per poterlo indirizzare e
non solo subire
e importante che il passo precedente
quello del recupero della complessità e
della capacità di lavorare su
informazione complessa sia fatto bene
anche per questo le istituzioni di
formazione le istituzioni culturali gli
archivi le biblioteche hanno oggi una
missione importantissima lavorare anche
all'interno dell'ecosistema digitale
portando anche all'interno
dell'intelligence del ecosistema
digitale la quel marchio della
complessità della capacità di lavorare
su informazione complessa che ha
caratterizzato progressivamente il
nostro sviluppo culturale
[Applauso]
[Musica]